hey guys it is much the first today my
name is Jess McDowell and he isn't
medicine gaming harmonics is currently
seeking crowdfunding support to bring
rockband swart PC the developer are
contributing $500,000 of their own money
to make the dream into a reality but
they're also asking for 1.5 million from
fans to get them over the line should
the campaign be funded rock band 4 will
come to PC in the fall of this year new
features will include the return of rock
band network which enables the ability
to create your own tracks the pc version
will also include all existing features
including monthly feature updates world
tour campaign mode free style guitar
solos 65 included songs with an
additional 33 available to backers and
support for existing wireless
instruments if you pledge $49 or more on
their big donation page you will get a
copy of the game the big crowd funding
platform is a little different in that
it offers traditional rewards for
pledges as well at investment
opportunities and includes people like
harmonic CEO Alex regardless and Double
Fine's Tim Schafer on the advisory board
next up gears of war Ultimate Edition is
out now on PC although things are going
all that smoothly Microsoft has
highlighted that the game is having
problems working with AMD Radeon
hardware but they're currently working
on a fix players with g-sync monitors
may be encountering framerate issues
which there are a couple of fixes and
Microsoft are also trying to rectify a
laptop related issue which spits out an
error claiming the selected GPU is not
supported by the game on top of that a
bunch of people are reporting issues
with simply getting the game downloaded
from the windows App Store the Ultimate
Edition features up to 4k resolution
with an unlocked refresh rate and five
extra campaign missions added on top of
the original PS
Master you know that is if you can get
it working you can also check out the
school system requirements in our story
on site finally Sony have revealed
details about the next major firmware
update of house for the 3.5 o patch will
allow you to appear offline while
connected to the PlayStation Network and
introduces remote place or PC and Macs
which will let you connect to your ps4
through your computer so long as you're
on the same home network in addition to
that there will be notifications when
your friends come online so you can know
immediately when to bug people to join
your party use a scheduled events so you
can plan their [ __ ] in advance and be
automatically added to a party and then
you play together feature which lets all
members of a party see what each person
is playing at all times to make joining
games together and stalking your pals
gaming habits way easier according to
Sony the beta for the new update will
roll out to select PlayStation users
soon let me know down in that comment
section what you're keen on in the new
ps4 update and be sure to have to
gamespot or we've got stories on the
possibility of the new Alan Wake and the
upcoming Xbox one system update that is
everything I have for you today but as
always let me know what you cared about
and I will catch you same time tomorrow